for sarah navid the lifting of mandates
has come with some concerns while i
completely understand that society needs
to go back to whatever normal is
um
that also means that a huge chunk of our
vulnerable population is going to be
stuck at home for a longer period of
time navida's immuno compromised and
lives with a family member who's very
vulnerable so to protect herself and her
loved ones i try to avoid big crowds i
am still distancing and wearing masks
only seeing close friends and family and
if i need to go to a grocery store or
need to make a trip to the mall i try to
go during times when i know it's not
going to be crowded there are many
canadians like naveed who are very
vulnerable and trying to protect
themselves during the sixth wave a
statistics canada report finds 38 of
canadians and private households have
one or more underlying health conditions
making them more vulnerable to
complications after contracting covet
19. it's an extremely dangerous time
right now for people who are
immunosuppressed but medicine professor
don baudisch says there are ways you can
try and protect yourselves still being
up to date on your vaccines is
incredibly important if you're
immunocompromised having a high quality
mask and reducing social contacts not
going to big events and since many
children are not eligible for vaccines
some of the
highest infection rates are in children
so limiting contact with children would
be helpful and if you do contract covet
19 bowdish suggests reaching out to your
family doctor to see if you qualify for
an antiviral pill she says every little
bit helps in saving lives and minimizing
hospitalizations
charming samani global news